in the last video I talked about how if
you're trying to maximize or minimize a
multi variable function you can imagine
its graph in this case this is just a
two variable function and we're looking
at its graph and you want to find the
spots where the tangent plane is
completely flat so one way to visualize
this is to imagine a flat plane that
just represents a constant Z value so a
constant output value for the function
and if you kind of move it up and down
you're looking for the spot where it
only barely intersects with the graph at
the top before it's not intersecting it
with it anymore meaning that there's no
values of the function that get above
that point so you're looking just for
where it's tangent where you can find a
tangent plane that's flat but this will
give you some other points like the
little local minima here the bumps where
the value of the function at that point
is higher than all of the neighbor
points you know if you walk in any
direction you're going downhill so
that's another thing you're going to you
know incidentally pick up by looking for
places where this tangent plane is flat
but there's also a really interesting
new possibility that comes up in the
context of multi variable functions and
this is the idea of a saddle point so
let me pull up another graph here this
guy and the function that you're looking
at here I'll write it down the function
that you're looking at is f of X y is
equal to x squared minus y squared okay
so now let's think about what the
tangent plane at the origin of this
entire graph would be now the tangent
plane to this graph at the origin is
actually flat here's what it looks like
and to convince yourself of this let's
go ahead and actually compute the
partial derivatives of this function and
evaluate each one at the origin so the
partial derivative with respect to X we
look here and x squared is the only spot
where an X shows up so it's 2x and the
other partial derivative the partial
with respect to Y with respect to Y we
take the derivative of this negative Y
squared and the we ignore the X because
it looks like a constant as far as Y is
concerned and we get negative 2y now if
we plug in the point the origin into any
one of these you know we plug in the
point XY is equal to zero zero then what
do each of these go to well the top one
x equals zero so this guy goes to zero
and similarly over here Y is zero so
this goes to zero so both partial
derivatives are Z
and what that means is if you are
standing at the origin and you move in
any direction
there's no slope to your movement and
one way of seeing this is to is to chop
the graph so if we imagine chopping it
with a plane that represents a constant
x-value and we kind of chop off the
graph there what you'll see here I'll
get rid of the tangent plane what you'll
see is that the curve where this
intersects the graph so let me trace
that out the curve where it intersects
the graph basically has a local maximum
at that origin point the tangent line of
the curve at that point in the Y
Direction is flat and it's because it
looks like a local maximum from that
perspective but now let's imagine
chopping it in a different direction so
if instead we have the full graph and
instead of chopping it with a constant
x-value we chop it with a constant Y
value then in that case we look at the
curve and if we trace out the curve
where this constant Y value intersects
the graph let's see what it would look
like it's also kind of this parabolic
shape again the tangent line is flat
because it looks like a local minimum of
that curve so because it's flat in one
direction and it's flat in the other
direction the tangent plane of the graph
as a whole is indeed going to be flat
but notice this is neither a local
maximum nor a local minimum because from
one direction from one direction it
looked like it was a local maximum you
know I'll get rid of that guy it looks
like it's a local maximum when you look
on the curve there but from another
direction if you chop it in another way
it looks like a local minimum and if we
look at the equations this kind of makes
sense because if you're just thinking
about movements in the X direction the
entire function looks like x squared
plus some kind of constant so the graph
of that would look like an x squared
parabola shape that has a local minimum
but if you're thinking of pure movements
in the Y direction and you're just
focused on that negative Y squared
component the graph that you get for
negative Y squared is going to look like
an upside-down parabola here I'll draw
that again it's going to look like an
upside-down parabola and that's got a
local maximum so it's kind of like the x
and y directions disagree over whether
this point whether this point where you
have a flat tangent plane should be a
local maximum or local minimum
and this is new to multivariable
calculus this is something that doesn't
come up in single variable calculus
because when you're looking at the graph
of a function you know you're looking at
some kind of graph if the tangent line
is zero
you know if the tangent line is
completely flat at some point either
it's a local maximum or it's a local
minimum it can't disagree because
there's only one input variable there's
only one you know X as the input
variable for your graph but once we have
two it's possible that they disagree and
this this kind of point has a special
name and the name is kind of after this
graph that you're looking at it's called
a saddle point saddle point and this is
one of those rare times where I actually
kind of like the terminology that
mathematicians have given something
because this looks like a saddle the
sort of thing that you would put on a
horse is back before writing it so one
thing that this means for us as we're
going to try to figure out ways to find
the absolute maximum or the minimum of a
function as we're trying to as we're
trying to optimize a function that might
represent you know represent like
profits of your company or a cost
function and a machine learning setting
or something like that is we're going to
have to be able to recognize if a point
is a saddle point and if you're just
looking at the graph that's fine you can
recognize it visually but oftentimes if
you're just given the formula of a
function it's some long thing without
looking at the graph how would you be
able to tell just by doing certain
computations to the formula whether or
not it's a saddle point and that comes
down to something called the second
partial derivative test which I will
talk about in the next few videos see
you then